all right everybody hello and welcome
back to the endgame class
as always my name is caleb denby and
tonight i wanted to take you through
some games uh some end games
specifically from the all-time
end game maestro uh jose raul capablanca
and specifically i wanted to look at a
couple cases
that sort of border on not being end
games sort of
border on just either queenless middle
games or
late late middle games transitioning to
the end game and the idea i want to talk
about
uh at least for the first few is the
idea of attacking the king
in end games it's not an idea that shows
up uh too often it's sort of unexpected
that you can go for checkmating attacks
attacks against the king
in the end game but it does happen and i
found quite a few examples
from cavablanca where he employs this
strategy uh to
great effect so let's just jump into it
uh flipping over here our first game is
going to be between
capablanco with the white pieces and
george allen
thomas with the black pieces uh and yeah
manny is asking in the chat hello every
everybody in the chat room watching live
uh asking if i've done a
stream about the berlin end game uh and
honestly i believe i have
i think i did a while ago uh maybe it
could use another update though so i
might come back to that
someday soon anyways let's jump into it
this is not the end game this is the
opening so we don't really care
uh but we are going to see some
interesting things uh developing out
in this uh opening and actually no i
don't want to start with this one we'll
come back to that game we'll come back
to that game i thought something didn't
look right
we are going to flip on over to
uh a game between cavablanca and yates
first apologies there so let's take a
look at this yeah this looks better
this looks better this is what i wanted
to start with so
what are we looking at well right now
this is not the end game this is an
endgame class
so i am flipping through all this until
we get to a position
that looks a little bit more manageable
so
here already i want to pause and
think about the positions so you are
welcome to argue with me
and tell me that this is not an endgame
but i'm going to argue queens are off
the board uh
two of the minor pieces have actually
also been traded off the board
and it's reasonably close to to
something like an
end game so i want to start our talk
about this position
from this point here and let's see what
you guys in the chat
think about this position i'm repeating
my quote i don't remember my quote is
uh toasted ravioli approved the road to
200 or 2000 maybe
road to 200 yeah okay
said bishop so yeah manny says sad
bishop and that's probably the first
thing to to notice
about this position so the reason why i
really want to focus
on a position like this is because a lot
of the time before you get to like a
pure end game with only one or two
pieces on the board
you're left with some position kind of
like this there are cases
where all the pieces sort of fall off
the board at the same time and you're
instantly in an end game but more often
than not
you're going to get some position with a
few pieces on the board and you still
have some work to do
so this is that weird in between phase
between the middle game and the end game
where you have to you know work on
getting towards a favorable end game
right now white obviously has some
pluses in the position because this
bishop is so sad
and the black pieces are a little bit
scattered but definitely not enough to
claim
any kind of winning advantage so the
trick now
is going to be figuring out how we can
convert a position like this
into a position that is a pure end game
that we know how to win that we know we
can win
and potentially should win so let's see
what kappa block does to get to a
position like that uh first and foremost
uh the next few moves are i think pretty
reasonable
uh and i think a lot of people would
would come with these as well first and
foremost we see capablanca just stepping
out of this pin with king b2
knight f6 by yates getting the knight
back into the game
and then capablanca simply activates the
the final piece that needs to be in the
game
he does so by just playing rook d2 and
rook h to d1
notably even after a5 this bishop is
still
pretty sad down here on uh on c8
now yates plays this move knights to uh
knight to d5
and this is another point when i want to
stop and ask you
how do we continue improving white's
position here
now is the time to start thinking about
the structure
right in a lot of end games the
difference between being better off and
being worse off
is your structure if you have a good
structure you
a lot of times can hold otherwise bad
positions or win
otherwise mediocre positions so how can
we start trying to improve capital
blocker structure
and even start thinking about breaking
down
yates's structure what do you think
okay there's a few ideas manny is saying
f3 not immediately because it hangs this
pawn
but as an idea f3 anything else
anything else so exquisite corpse
actually says uh
white has to solve the king black has to
solve the bishop so
kind of in a sense uh white has to solve
the king but
uh in a position like this with so many
pieces on the board you don't
necessarily even want your king on a
square like e5
maybe in this exact case it wouldn't be
so bad but
uh what's good for white is that the
king at least has a quick path into the
game
so if we ever trade off a few more
pieces you'll see white's king is very
quickly ready to act whereas this bishop
probably should
really be in the game quite quickly so
okay
there's this idea of e4 the idea of h5
the idea of g3 and even the id of f3 so
everybody wants to push one of the pawns
on the king's side
fair enough
[Music]
okay so uh half of you are right
and half of you are wrong i don't think
f3
is really doing much in the way of
helping white's position but
g3 is actually the move that capablanca
plays
now i said half of you are right now
obviously g3 is only a quarter of the
moves listed
and that's because this idea of e4 is in
fact
a good one in my opinion now why is this
move so good well
let's take a moment and see what
position it actually gets played in
first we have rook f7 by yates which
makes a lot of sense to activate this
rook uh
seeing that this knight on c5 isn't
going to last here forever
kappa blanc uh kappablanca actually
takes a moment to reroute it
we see rook b7 going after this pawn on
b3
knight e5 and rook c to c7 so black
really taking a a little more a little
bit more of a passive approach guarding
the seventh rank
but still having active rooks on open
files and this is actually the position
where capablanca plays the move e4
and uh sorry it's not the position where
kappa block can play z4 kappa blanca
defends the e4 square first
and now in this position plays the move
e4 and i want to talk a little bit
about this move and why i think it's
such a good
practical move objectively it doesn't
really change the evaluation of the
position all that much
but it shows uh it's sort of the perfect
move
for this transition period between the
middle game
and the end game so capablanca is giving
yates a
choice in this position uh choice number
one is to
take the pawn kev blanco will take back
and then black will be faced with a
weakness in the structure
compared to white's one pawn island with
all the pawns still together
of course we know in the end game the
fewer pawn islands tends to be better
because you have fewer weaknesses to
guard
for black these two pawns can both be
attacked for white
only this one in the immediate position
the other choice
is to potentially move the knight from
the d5 square with something like knight
to f6
but then we'll see that uh white might
be able
to invade along the d file at a later
date
not immediately clear that that's going
to happen right away but this is
something
that black is going to have to keep an
eye on to be sure
for example white can sort of keep the
tension with something like f3
we see that now both sides get sort of a
fractured structure
but now there's nothing preventing these
rooks from invading
a little bit later on in the game so
in the game yates picks this idea of f
takes e4 and rook takes e4
and i think honestly this is probably
the the beginning of the end
uh i don't see a real reason for black
to actually adopt
this weaker weaker structure i very much
prefer the move knight f6
sort of keeping the tension yes you now
have to worry about the middle game
threats of the rooks invading
but your end games are not going to be
so sad as they are
after f takes e4 and rook takes c4
so i think this is actually a really
really pivotal moment
in the game where we see black actually
making a mistake
that could turn out to be fatal not
saying black is losing in this position
already
but i i don't even know if black was
much worse at all
after the move knight f6 and this is
something capablanca does a really great
job at
that i think is perhaps sometimes
overlooked maybe not at all actually
uh because cap blanca is sort of widely
recognized as one of the best endgame
players of all time
but it's this middle game to end game
transition period
where i think capablanca also shined
quite well
he uses middle game type of threats like
activating the rooks
and coming after a slightly exposed king
combined with the threat of getting into
a better end game
giving the opponent this option do you
want to be under pressure right now
or do you want to accept a slightly
worse end game and under the pressure
yates simply picks the wrong decision by
taking on e4
ok the game continues now with rook to
b5 trying to activate along the fifth
rank a little bit
and now we actually see uh cappa blanca
having weakened black structure say okay
i've had enough of all these pieces now
let's take these off the board and i
will happily win the better end game
with
this massive weakness sitting here on e6
and my knight well placed on c4 to
challenge the weakness on
a5 as well his bishop
is the worst yes everybody get your fred
the worst jokes out of the way now okay
so now we see the move bishop d7 uh by
black
trying to activate this bishop one way
or another and
capablanca finally brings the snipe back
into the game with knight c3
notably right after black makes this
decision to weaken the structure
giving himself a worse end game we see
kappa blanca's next
uh three moves rook c4 trades a piece
knight takes c4 takes a piece back and
knight c3 offers a trade of pieces right
uh capiblanca understands that with this
weakening of the structure
black's end games are going to be tough
especially with this bishop versus this
knight
and so you know capablanca doesn't shy
away from
starting to offer some traits now
obviously this one can't even be taken
because rick takes d7 comes with check
but interesting to point out nonetheless
all right we have rook c5 and now knight
e4 continuing to advance with these
knights
uh knight back to b5 or rook back to b5
and now the knight invades on d6
we see rook over to c5 and knight b7 now
and black's position has crumbled we see
that the pawn falls on a5
and now black not only has the worst
structure but is down
upon on the queen's side uh and this is
also down
to white's king actually being usefully
placed guarding a weakness
on this side of the board as well
whereas after this knight on c4 gets
established it's just sort of impossible
to guard this pawn on a5 from here the
the rest is sort of history
we see cappa blanca finally playing this
move f4
this is another move i wanted to
highlight it's a good restrictive move
to keep black's pieces or black
structure sort of at bay
keeping it from advancing any further
and keeping these pawns all sort of
uh in a state where they could be
attacked much like the move g3
earlier which i want to scroll back to
really quickly i sort of
zoomed past this move but g3 is a great
move to stop black from getting activity
with the move
f4 looking to activate this way uh
important to point out these restricting
moves as well
from capoblanca so okay f4 and now we
see the knight landing back on e5 after
bishop e8
rook a8 and now uh kappa blanca just
continues improving the pieces
with rook c1 bishop f7 and now rook c6
and it's just quite clear that yates
never
really stood a chance in this end game
did black ever have a chance to
liquidate the isolated e pawn
uh i don't think that that black really
did um
white was uh keeping a pretty good
control
over the e5 square with the knight on c4
and then bringing the knight back to e5
eventually
and it wasn't as if there was some
tactical way to trade off this pawn uh
yates has sort of just been stuck with
this guy
for the entire game we see bishop back
to g8 and
the sadness of this bishop now really
does continue
uh from here pretty much everything wins
so i don't want to spend too much more
time on this end game
we see knight c5 by cappa blanca ricky
aids
pawn was attacked had to defend it
somehow rook a6 now
just brings the rook further away from
the king and allows it access to the
seventh rank
uh rook e7 defends against this and now
we see capablanca just getting ready to
push the past pawn
uh as you do in an end game where you
have an extra passed pawn
uh knight c7 attacks a rook so we see
rook c6
and not rook a7 hanging a fork
we see knight out to b5 trying to
blockade king back to b2 is fine
now knight d4 hits the rook again rick
a6 bishop eights
and now i want to pause one more time
uh okay we zoomed through a lot of moves
there because they are either pretty
intuitive moves
uh not very instructive moves just you
know sort of shuffling around
uh attacking uh the weakness but now
it's decision time right
uh white tried the plan of pushing the
extra past pawn
it got up to b4 and now we see black is
very ready to blockade this
pawn with these two pieces so what
should white do
now to continue making progress up to
this point it's been pretty easy we just
got ready to push our pawn forward and
then did now though
we are being met with resistance b5 is
well defended how
should we advance here
how to advance and dev chest world i
would ask that you
only type your moves one time
rather than 30. only eat it one time
but dev chest world nonetheless says
king c3
exquisite corpse also says king c3
to uh to c4 chess player says knight d7
which seems to be a tactical option
reroute the 95 the e5 knight
so uh
so king c3 is not the worst move ever i
i would ask you to understand
that you're hanging upon perhaps
and yeah manny has the idea of g4
and f5 interestingly attack the knight
with the king
so uh incredibly here the correct move
is the move that kappa blanco plays
which is actually the move of g4
uh and this move isn't like immediate
immediately trying to play the move f5
or anything it's just taking a little
bit of extra space
on this side of the board and following
a very important principle
that uh that i've talked about many
times before and that's the principle of
two weaknesses and i think it's sort of
a poorly named principle
and i'll tell you why uh the principle
of two weaknesses
means you have a weakness on either side
of the board
that you can attack then your opponent's
you know forces get stretched thin
trying to defend both weaknesses at the
same time and they just can't
keep both of them together now i think
it's poorly named
because in this case the quote-unquote
weakness
on the queen side is actually just this
extra pawn for white it's not like white
is attacking a weakness on the queen
side
white is simply threatening to push the
pawn forward and that
is the factor that stretches black's
forces thin on the queen side
meanwhile on the king's side we do
already have a weakness that we're
attacking
on e6 and this is going a long way
towards immobilizing blacks
pieces but we can do even better by
trying to create threats on this side of
the board
by creating a past pawn over here as
well so with g4
white is trying to do just that white is
giving himself
the opportunity to play a move like f5
later on
or at least continue coming after
black's pawns over here with even an
eventual g5 as well just creating
threats on the other side of the board
and this is a great thing to try to do
whenever you see
that your opponent is uh
um is for the moment stopping your play
on the side of the board where you where
you really want to play
in addition though g4 not only does all
this but it allows for king c3 because
this is no longer
going to be a fork uh we see king f6 in
the game trying to defend
e6 but now 94 check by capablanca
king back to g7 and knight d6 so
uh as i said uh black's forces stretched
a little bit thin already with the pawn
on e6 and the pawn on b4
and now capoblanca is looking perhaps to
even simplify things a little bit
further or just continue activating the
pieces
all right we have rook b or bishop b5 by
yates rook
a5 and now this blockade must go
bishop down to f1 and rook up to a8
is kappa blanca's choice b5 would
probably be a little bit premature
uh why well maybe even you know black
considers sacrificing a piece for it
but uh other than that b5 is honestly
probably fine here
um but okay rook a8 instead is trying to
play for more even than the extra piece
and we see black trying desperately to
simplify things now
on the king's side with g5
f takes g5 by cappa blanca you should
take this extra pawn
uh we get take six sticks and now bishop
g2 and we see
black sort of preparing to blockade this
pawn
on a new square of b7 uh ricky ada's
played offering the
trade of rooks but now rook c7
and eventually we see some funny traits
rook d8 threatening knight e8 so we see
knight c6
98 king f8 takes on c7 takes on e8
and now i wanted to show you the the
beautiful finish to uh to this game
the beautiful finish
wait you still hang a pawn with king c3
though so yeah important to note
important to note that while king c3 was
likely on
the agenda here uh it would still for
the moment be be hanging upon so
if uh black were to pass which is
honestly quite difficult to do let's say
okay bishop e5 isn't really passing
let's say king g8 let's say you go king
c3
knight e2 check knight takes f4 uh the
point here is is that b5 is is still
probably worth it but
g4 gaining more space nonetheless and
you don't necessarily even have to play
uh king c3 after move like that i think
g5 is probably
in line with what uh capoblanco was was
planning
and if hg5 then even uh f takes g5
perhaps and you truly do solve this
problem good good to point out though
moving along we have this weird trade of
rooks
and now uh king c3 bishop b7 and the
beautiful
finish to this game so we have two
knights
against a knight in a bishop and
thankfully we have two past pawns to
work with as well
two past pawns to work with
okay let us let us move forward i'm
sorry i was just catching up on the chat
there for a second
uh king d4 is pretty normal you just
advance the king use the king of the end
game get the king in front of the past
pawns
bishop c8s g6 all makes sense
knight b7 and now i would like you guys
to find the the tactical finish
that uh that capablanca finds kappa
blocking manages
to force resignation after five more
moves
which doesn't sound like a lot but uh
but
i guess kind of is enough
so white to move and win see if you can
find
the beautiful knockout blow and that's
why i was saying that a large part of
this
uh lecture tonight is about going after
the king in the end game
even here we can go after black's king
and yeah simon actually does have the
correct first move yeah king e4
is like a normal move it doesn't spoil
anything by any means
but 98 is is the beautiful finish
of course this cannot be captured
because after g7
this is simply going to promote the king
cannot access either the f8
or the f7 squares uh
in the meantime you know what else can
black do
this bishop is sort of stuck back on the
c8 square where it was stuck 30 moves
ago
uh and aside from that you know life is
pretty tough
uh yates tried 98 in the game now we see
kappa blanca simply play b5
and after king g8 we now see
g5 king f8 and now
white to move and win it's actually
forced checkmate in just a couple moves
here
maybe more than a couple but uh still
force checkmate
who sees the checkmate look into your
mind's eye
find find out how to checkmate this king
okay don't just give me the first move
everybody everybody sees the first move
of course g7 is the first move but find
the checkmate
find the checkmate
and yes so simon almost has it there
simon almost has it
uh let's put it on the board we have g7
king g8 and g6 and the point now
is that this king is actually completely
immobilized
no legal moves for the king and now no
matter what
uh black plays we are going to have a
path
to uh to checkmate with the other knight
now if black plays something like knight
b7
we actually can't go knight g4 because
e5 check is losing our piece
but if this bishop were to move out of
the way then knight g4 is perfectly fine
with e5 check being the only way to
delay things
and after this check we simply move away
with checkmate to follow
and that is simply checkmate knight b7
for example
would run into knight f7
or knight c6 i think even and knight h6
mate
unstoppable so capo blanca finding a way
to check mate the king
uh even in this endgame uh yates
actually resigns after move g6
rather than uh rather than play on
knight takes e5 that loses nothing but
it's not checkmate
it's not checkmates
and yeah exquisite corpse put the the
other line in the chat there obviously
if king takes e8
then white just makes a queen you can
even go knight g6
check and i think this is just
going to be mate so that's the first
game i wanted to go over i thought this
was instructive for a couple reasons
uh it was kind of run-of-the-mill
technique by capablanco with the extra
pawn for a while
but the first big thing i wanted to
really really highlight is this idea of
e4 uh this is the thing to take away
from the game kappa blanca
balancing middle game ideas with endgame
ideas
in order to make progress uh in in this
game
giving his opponent the option do you
want to suffer
my active rooks or do you want to suffer
in a slightly worse end game
yates picked the end game and
unfortunately for yates these two pawns
proved to be too big to uh to survive so
interesting stuff
what year was this that's an excellent
question let me check the pgn tags
1924 1924
why not move the other knight for the
faster mate well this knight is actually
serving a purpose
uh it has to guard the g7 pawn this
knight moves
then um this is not checkmate
uh okay let's move along though let's
move along up next i wanted to highlight
this game between cappa blanca in one
leopoldo leopold i can't say that name
leopoldo
carranza uh who i believe is in
argentine argentinian player back in the
day
uh i think if my chess history is
correct
by chess history i mean the comments i
read under like the the chess games uh
entry for this
i think this was part of an exhibition
that capoblanca did where he
sort of traveled traveled around and
played the best players from argentina
argentina not known for the best chess
players in like 1911 i think
but uh still put up a good fight here so
let's take a look now normally
in the end game class i just scroll
through this opening bit because nobody
cares
but i i gotta show you this one cappa
blanca plays f6
so that's why i bothered telling you
that this was supposed to be some kind
of like exhibition match between like
argentina's best players in capablanca
because i think i think i think captain
block was meme in a little bit i think
he was pulling out a meme or two here
playing f6 against uh you know his
distinguished
argentinian opponent so f6 is a little
bit weird
not a great opening for capablanca but
he manages to turn it around
uh quite quickly in fact with uh
a couple trades and king's side castles
and then all of a sudden this rook on fh
just looks very active
seemingly out of nowhere we see even
more trades
and knight to d2 and let's see when do i
want to start
looking uh we'll go a little bit further
up to this trade here
we see all the pieces come off the board
aside from the rooks and we are solidly
in an
end game so what are your thoughts on
this endgame chat room i think it's
always always always a good idea to
pause
both in these lectures and in your real
games whenever
a lot of pieces have been traded off the
board and you find yourself in sort of a
wildly new position so that's just
happened
so what do we think is going on here
let's try and assess
let's try and assess the pyramid opening
always
looks so awkward so yeah you tend to see
the triangle defense uh
against d4 with d5 but uh
here we see capoblanca adopting a
different type of triangle
different type of triangle
see you guys are starting to notice the
uh
the the really important features in the
position so it's pretty
plain to see that black structure is a
little bit better black has
you know this really strong advanced d4
pawn black has a little bit more space
which does make a difference in some
end games and white is dealing with uh
this double pawn here on b3
and this slightly backward pawn on f3
but
what's really important isn't you know
how these pawns look black's pawns look
better
but what is important in these end games
is black's ability
to create a past pawn or threaten to
create a past pawn
so what's important isn't so much this
d4 pawn
but the path for this pawn to become a
queen for
ins you know for that to happen it has
to get past white's pawns first
so thinking long term we need to find
some way
for us to try and advance this deep on
even
further so chat room who has some plans
for how to make this a reality
how can we make this a reality
how can we make the d pawn passive
and yeah there's some some ideas in the
chat already maybe you're ahead of me
so b5 c5 c4 and d3 so this is going to
be a really critical idea
pushing c5 and b5 and c4 giving yourself
this option to push d3
any other plans for making this d-pawn
passed
any other plans c5 b5 c4 and yeah
everybody loves
c5 b5 c4 so this is a pretty good plan
but capablanca
actually does manage to improve upon it
slightly
in the game so we'll see if you can spot
uh spot the improvement as we go along
here this is
sort of the core of the plan though so
good job figuring that out guys it's not
just about having the prettier structure
it's about being able to create a past
pawn which kappa blanca is
able to do first though we do see c5
and what's really important in the
endgames well it's king activity
so before these sort of uh long-term
plans of improving the structure
creating a past pawn
we're gonna see both sides take time out
of their days to get the kings in the
game
and now we do see b5 by black and
king d2 by white and i did not mean to
spoil this move
but this is another great restricting
pawn move by cava blanca
it's not all about improving the
structure on the queen side
it's also about holding back white
structure on the king's side
where white has a 4-3 majority so g5
great move
keeping any f4 breaks at bay making sure
there's not going to be any surprises
here
notably if white wanted to try something
like that a little bit earlier
unfortunately it would leave this uh
leave this e pawn a little bit behind
and this this pawn is just going to be
too weak
for this to be a good idea in this
position
but still worth uh sort of blocking this
idea off
we see h3 by whites and now i'm curious
what you guys think capablanca plays
next we have our long-term plan
of trying to make a past pawn out of
this d-pawn somehow
but obviously white is effectively
blockading this pawn right now
and white is also you know staying quite
solid
quite compact
hello to felipe by the way hello hello
so ariel is the pers the first person
i've seen to
uh andronis actually have both mentioned
this idea
but playing a4 instead of c4 is actually
going to be
a pretty good idea here now what is the
point of playing a4
rather than playing c4 uh at first
glance it looks like you're simply
fixing
white's double pawns but it gives your
rooks
a path number one to enter the game
along the a file making use of this
extra space somewhat
and number two if this a pawn can be
diverted
to a4 and black can take back with a
rook then we have
a much much much easier time of playing
the move c4
than we do right now with this pawn on
p3
but first things first kappa blanca
takes as much space as possible
on the king side and i think this is
another great idea by cappa blanca
why allow the opponent any opportunity
to later play g3 and h4
or f4 so captain blanca simply doesn't
we see
h5 and now after g4 by white
sort of admitting defeat i think this is
actually quite a bad move
simply h4 by kappa blanca and the king's
side has been completely locked down
before going for this play on the queen
side
so b takes a four you take with the rook
well let's see what kappa blanca does
hello to tacotopia tackytopia chess
going through a lot of capablanca
endgames there's a lot to do a lot to do
so yeah this g4 move is it's just pretty
bad by white
i don't have an explanation here i think
we we can all see why
it leaves the f pawn behind it removes
any fluidity in
in the position but uh notably if an
idea like g3 had been played i think
capablanco was probably intending
h4 either forcing this pawn forward or
forcing similar weaknesses over here
again playing on both sides of the board
instead we see white trying to mitigate
this by closing up this side of the
board
but obviously now this pawn is going to
be weak as well
so king e2 is played and now rook f7 is
the idea employed in the game
with this rook a7 idea and unfortunately
for white
due to having this weakness on f3 it
isn't very easy
for white to just totally abandon the
king's side and do something like this
uh trying to you know counter this a4
push maybe this is what white should
have done
but it's definitely not easy to get away
with and notably
this may also just be a winning king in
pawn end game um
and by maybe i i i mean to say
definitely is
definitely is just a winning king upon
end game so no
good uh ideas for white here so instead
we see white allowing capoblanca to play
this a4 idea and after b takes a4
as manny asked in the chat do you play
rook takes a for uh
of course you do because it's about
getting your rooks
active and it's about our plan of
creating a past pawn on this side of the
board
so a4 we definitely want rook takes a
four
um although sorry cavablanca actually
inserts c4 check first
keeping with the game and then rick
takes a four
uh and here the the end is sort of
already near for
white we see rook b1 but now rook a1
and you know capablanca is simply
invading
rook f to f1 and we see takes on b1
and takes on b1 so i wanted to pause
here again we have made a lot of
progress so far
in the position it might not look like
that much is different
by but by opening the a file uh
maintaining our active rook against
white's passive rook
uh securing the king's side and further
advancing our pawns in the center slash
queen side
black has made a ton a ton of progress
and it went from being a very pleasant
position
to i think strictly being a winning
position
that being said there is still work to
be done here
the king and pawneen game i showed is
losing okay i'll go back to that a
little bit later but let's
uh show this one first i'm pretty sure
black is just winning
in that endgame but i will go back to it
later
let's focus on this so this is winning
but
uh that being said winning is not the
same as one
what do i mean well i mean black still
does have to find some ideas
in order to uh to end this game so first
things first
capablanca posts this rook up on the a2
square
ensuring it is staring at the white king
and immobilizing the queen side pawns a
bit
we see king d1 by carranza and now
how does black continue how should we
change the structure further
how do we change the structure further
so everybody's saying b4 interesting
that you guys have abandoned your idea
of d3
you guys have abandoned the idea of d3
b4 then b3 that's interesting
so i do like this move b4 i think this
is the correct way to change the
structure
but you do have to realize something uh
pretty serious about this move
right away uh and that is what happens
on white's move b3 what is your plan
here
what are your intentions you have to
have something ready
in response to white's move b three
so captures is actually probably the the
worst of the options i think available
to black
so this is the one i was hoping you guys
would avoid because this allows white
out of the j
out of the jail cell that the rook was
in suddenly this rook is very very
active
but yeah you guys do have some good
ideas black i think
can play c3 and you can actually also
play the move d3
but it's with the idea of playing c3 to
follow not with
simply taking when this pawn might
actually be a bit loose it's about
playing c3 here
so uh in the game this doesn't actually
happen we see carranza play king d2
first
and then after the king shuffle we now
now we do see b3
and kappa blanca chooses the move c3 and
i wanted to highlight this a little bit
because for the moment it looks as if
this is giving up on the plan
of creating a past pawn so this seems to
go against some of the logic that i was
dictating a little bit earlier on
in the class so why why does capoblanca
do this
why not make a past pawn directly and
the reason is here
there's simply no good way for white to
stop the move d3
alright d3 is coming anyways and rather
than
the left uh looking here rather than be
left with a weak past pawn on d3
capoblanca is still going for this idea
of sacrificing the d-pawn and getting a
strong passed pawn
on c3 a defended pass pawn and allowing
the king an
inroad so that's what's going on here it
looks as though
it might not be it might be giving up on
the idea of a past pawn
but it's actually not at all d3 is going
to be unstoppable you can't even play
king e2
because that's check and if king d3
that's that's me
uh so okay now rook to c1 played in the
game trying to stop d3
but of course we just played anyways we
get pawn takes d3
and now uh capoblanca really does put
put kronzo away pretty quickly here rook
h2
is the devastating move uh we see rook
c2
going for a trade of rooks
but uh you don't even get that if you're
karan's the king and pawn end game is in
fact losing
but instead we just get check and king
d4 and
this is total zug's fun
uh no way to improve the position here
for uh
for white unfortunately
why not king d4 king d4 also wins it
does not matter
does not matter
see oyster mentions that's uh cap blanca
has the reputation of being one of the
greatest zen game players but he goes
into the end game with an advantage
and that's something i sort of touched
on in the first game
we talked about uh capoblanca i think
really excelled
at this transition phase between the
middle game and the end game he would
give this
his opponents this choice where it's
like okay
do you want to give me this activity in
the middle game or do you want to ruin
your structure a little bit so that i
have a good end game and and that is
something that uh
i think he used to to great effect so
uh white is just totally busted here you
can't move anything because your king
gets checkmated
and you lose your rook uh and yeah it's
it's just devastating
so cool to note how capablanca treats
the structures in this
end game i think it's pretty masterful
stuff uh
the thing to keep in mind is that you
can sort of start to see things like
this coming
already from from this position here so
we see
how capablanca was intending in the long
in the long run to get this break of a4
through get c4 through and eventually
expand even further
to just roll over white on the queen
side good stuff
uh okay let us move along to
the last game uh x i lied i promised i
was to go over the king and pawn end
game
so if rook a2 rook a7 or k1
this is what we were looking at
and yeah this is just just winning for
black i think
i think this is just winning for black
you can play king d3
i just go this way and i'm not sure what
you uh what you intend to do
you ever go b through i go a3 if you
ever go c3
i can just take i think and i have the
outside
passive pawn the outside password pawn
is quite good quite good
i don't think your breakthrough
sacrifice actually works i can take
oops and life is good life is good
okay good question about that kingpin
game it's not quite as
you know straightforward as you might
expect but i think black is winning
there
all right let's move on to uh to the
final game yet unless
to the final game now unless anybody
else has any questions
all right moving along let's take a look
at nimzovich v capablanca
this game is pretty famous uh and i
couldn't remember
ever going over it on stream but i think
this one is famous enough that a lot of
you
have probably seen it already and if
honestly there is a possibility that i
have gone over it i just couldn't
remember doing it
but i couldn't believe i hadn't done it
because it's such a famous end game
we have capablanca playing the kerala
con nobody cares it's not a class about
the caracon it's class about endgames
okay but already here we're only on move
19
and there's a lot of pieces on the board
but i sort of want to stop and pause
here
can black improve the king before
committing b4
uh i think that's that's also fine yeah
i don't think black needed to rush to
play b4 for any reason but
like there was no problem with doing it
immediately their grey wolf
so i don't see why not
so i already want to stop and pause here
you might claim that this is not an
end game uh and you you might be right
but i think it is
related to the end game at the very
least which is why i wanted to pause
here
so who should be better in this position
well it all comes down
to the structure this is one of those
keracon positions where white committed
to advancing these pawns very very
quickly and as a result
has sort of left himself with a backward
pawn here on
f4 that's not going to be easy to solve
and another weakness here on
on h4 perhaps meanwhile in true carocon
style
black has gone through life trying to
make as few weaknesses as possible
and has for the most part succeeded
although we'll see
that perhaps there is one weakness that
black does have to keep in mind
all right sia arnov thanks for thanks
for hanging out uh in the meantime
uh the question still remains how does
black
get from this position to an end game
where black can really make use of these
weaknesses here
and that's what i want to look at here
with what kappa blanca plays
the first steps are still pretty uh
normal just queen b6 getting on this
diagonal
hitting this pawn we see rook f2
defending now rook c8
rook fc8 rather activating this rook now
a3
rook c7 preparing to double uh rook d3
and now knight a5 so capablanca is just
improving the pieces for the moment
i do want to mention that perhaps
capablanca could have considered taking
on d4 but we'll see this comes into play
later
uh now we see a weird move rookie 2 and
a weird move rookie 8 in response i
think they're playing a little dance
around this move
f5 and making sure that black is a good
way to capture this pawn for the moment
but in the meantime we see king g2
knight c6
and i am going to fast forward a little
bit until we get the knights off the
board
because that's where i really want to
focus in again okay so knight f5
by capablanca offering the trade of
knights
sort of at uh at white's discretion here
and we do actually see now knight takes
f5
played by nimzovich and g takes f5
played by cap blanca so what do you guys
think about
this decision good decision bad decision
awful decision the h5 pawn is hanging
maybe it's not
what is a backwards pawn so b 2 is in a
sense a backwards pawn here so a
backwards pawn
is upon where its neighboring pawns have
pushed forward
and can no longer defend it so f4 is
the most notable backwards pawn because
for example there can never be a pawn on
g3
that defends it so they do tend to be a
little bit weak because they have to be
defended by pieces
rather than their fellow pawn cohorts
so yeah tactically this move actually
does work out queen takes h5
isn't a good move because rook h8 comes
i mean f3 is forced and then rook h4
comes
and this is the the devastating idea
that um
that would be be winning the game uh if
white were to take on h5
rook d4 unfortunately isn't helping
matters that much
we can take take check
and just take on d4 and white is both
getting checkmated and losing the f4
pawn so
difficult stuff all ready for white
so tactically this move works out but
now that leaves us the question
of what happens if white just plays some
normal looking move
what happens here was it a good decision
positionally
to uh to trade the knights and and that
is sort of at the heart of the matter
and that's the main point i wanted you
guys to to take away
from this position it's why i mentioned
that black could take on d4 a little bit
earlier
and that actually increases winning
winning chances as opposed to uh you
know decreases winning chances
by by trading off these pieces so why
does it help so much
well looking at all these moves black
has all this firepower on the fourth
rank that would love to attack the f4
pawn
but it simply cannot because this knight
can never really be
forced off its powerful d4 outpost so
at the cost of slight structural
weaknesses uh capoblanca offers up this
trade again
and is happy to accept the weakness of
the h5 pawn
to get rid of the workhorse almost
literally
on d4 that was keeping all of black's
firepower out of the game
so with this knight out of the way black
now has sort of
free reign to attack this guy on f4
also to make threats of opening things
up further with a move like d4
so really important trade to take note
of here again
that middle game to end game transition
capablanca just understood
that this knight had to be dealt with so
queen f3
and now king g6 and this is the second
part
of why this decision was not a bad one
with king g6
black just really really effectively
defends the h5 pawn with the king
and it may look a little bit scary to be
you know hiding around all this
uh all these attacked squares by these
pawns but the fact of the matter is the
position is closed enough that white is
not able to really access this king
the game continues though with rick e to
d2 notably nimzovich is trying
very very hard to regain control of this
d4
square and that is the last thing
capoblanca can allow
so how should we continue to make sure
nimsovich can't
stop us up again by controlling d4
how should we continue
we have to make sure that we don't get
totally stopped up with
rook t4
and yeah as i think a lot of you are
pointing out
the key is to get the second rook into
the game
rook a4 was suggested but i think rook
e4 is in fact the better
version and the point now is that after
rook d4 we simply bring in the second
rook
with rook up to c4 uh and now
while white does for the moment have
this sort of
uh kind of blockade you know in
quotation marks on d4
it's not actually stopping all that much
it's true that white can hold
you know this blockade with the queen on
f2 but now
black still has pressure on the f4 pawn
regardless it's sort of like this rook
almost isn't even here
right this rook is still somehow
attacking f4 with like an x-ray attack
uh in the position so after queen f2
how does capablanca continue well he
continues with sort of the meanest move
which is queen to b5 now we see king to
g3
by nimzovich sort of perhaps
anticipating a move like queen a4
which would further increase the
pressure and now we see
uh capoblanca make a very interesting
decision to actually take
on d4 and the point now is that
uh white's blockade on d4 is meaningless
because
all of black's remaining pieces have
found their way into the position
regardless for example if rick takes d4
simply losing to rook e2 when queen
takes b2 comes along
and white is actually getting checkmated
so c takes d4 played instead
and now uh capoblanca
shows some really fun end game technique
here so i think most people would agree
that this one is in fact an end game
with only a queen and a rook left on the
board for both sides
and a very rare idea in the end game
although perhaps not so much
in major peace end games is to simply
win the game by
checkmate and that's what capablanca
does here
yes the multitude of weaknesses in
white's camp are what allows black
uh to go for this checkmating attack but
still nonetheless the checkmating attack
is a very important idea
and end games like these so capoblanca
sort of balances
attacking these weak pawns on the queen
side and in the center
with making threats to the king and that
is the winning technique here we see
queen to c4
starting to weasel their way in king to
g2
now b5 b4 taking the extra space
take take king g2 and now queen c1
and the the weaseling continues uh queen
c1 over to h1
and squares are being taken away from
this white king
rook to d3 now rook to e1 and stuff like
g1 is coming uh rook f3
rook d1 b3 and now the the killer killer
move
rooks c1 uh and in fact uh white
is incomplete uh zugswang here there's
simply no way
to improve the position and every move
is in fact
detrimental uh if this queen were to
move
you're going to be met by rook c3 or
i guess no probably queen g1
is the example and now if you block
simply queen takes d4
so you cannot move the queen because of
this threat if queen d2 for example
now rook g1 is going to be the idea with
checkmate to follow
very very shortly sorry queen takes f3
not queen f1
and if you move this rook then you see
the idea
as shown in the game which is rook f1
and this is also going to be devastating
with similar checkmating ideas here
queen g2 loses the rook and anything
else
uh loses loses the game quite quickly as
well rick f2 for example
and white is just totally busted so just
like that
capoblanco wins the game and it all
stems from this move knight f5
getting these knights off the board you
had uh to break this blockade with the
black pieces
and capoblanca does just that add the
slight risk to his own structure
but it doesn't make a difference once
he's able to break through
uh okay so we are running out of time
here i do
want to save some time for analyze your
games uh which is going on
on twitch directly after this show so i
think i
am going to call it here
so thank you all ver oh that's not what
i wanted
um thank you all very much for joining
me on this edition of the end game class
as always my name is caleb denby and i
will see you
next time goodbye everyone
you